so how many of you out there can
remember those arguments you had with
your friends on the playground as a kid
about which console was the best which
games were the best who had the best
exclusive titles trust me i can remember
as a kid arguing sega versus nintendo
and then of course later playstation vs
microsoft versus nintendo and it's funny
how as i've gotten older console wars
and where you play has become so much
less of an issue and i think i know why
you see as a kid so many of us were
limited to just one console my parents
could not understand the need of another
console you have this why do you need
that and so as a result of this we form
teams we form our own little tribe
around our console and we want to fight
for our console to be the best because
after all it's the only one we're gonna
have until the next generation as i've
gotten older though and have had more
disposable income where i can afford
having multiple consoles i'm really
starting to see the absurdity of all of
this and how at the end of the day the
hardware itself actually matters very
little in fact in today's environment
we're seeing a shift away from
exclusives with microsoft going all in
by offering all of their first party
titles on pc day one right alongside the
console counterpart on the other hand
you have nintendo who continues to make
titles exclusively for their platform
alone it wasn't until 2016 that they
finally started making mobile games even
featuring some of their most iconic
characters and somewhere in the middle
you have playstation who have recently
dipped their toe into the pc market by
releasing titles like horizon zero dawn
days gone uncharted legacy of thieves
and even the 2018 god of war it
certainly doesn't seem like their first
party titles will be hitting pc the same
day as consoles in the immediate future
but according to president and ceo jim
ryan it certainly sounds like
playstation is getting ready to make a
massive shift in its gaming business
that will be transformational for the
company and ultimately change the face
of playstation as we know it we have big
plans for fy 22 and beyond with
exponential growth anticipated in the
year just begun and with the opportunity
for our new life services strategy to
boost our pc revenues even more
aggressively in the years to come ryan
recently spoke with investors about the
state of playstation and this talk
included a wide range of subjects
including playstation on pc mobile live
service games the metaverse and even
when he ultimately expects the ps5
supply issues to finally subside which
sadly doesn't look like it will happen
until next year when it comes to
playstation titles on pc there are a few
slides of interest and it actually
starts with the very first slide ryan
shares you can see here they've
identified ps5 and ps4 as their thriving
core business so essentially playstation
currently views home consoles as the
major cog in their thriving core
business next we have a section
highlighting new growth vectors across
three categories commercial portfolio
and audience the one we're focused on in
this video is the third one the audience
which lists pc mobile and beyond console
as growth opportunities we won't talk
much about beyond console in this video
but essentially that's expanding to more
things like movies and tv shows slides
31 through 35 expand on the audience
piece further and there you'll see that
sony is expecting exponential growth
from their pc titles in 2022 and beyond
just take a look at the graph here they
expect the revenue from pc to nearly
quadruple in the 2022 fiscal year alone
now if we jump to slide 34 this one
shows a color-coded graph and judging
from the light blue section we can see
that playstation expects to double the
amount of pc titles they release by
2025. now in the q a that followed
ryan's presentation he was asked for
further clarification on this particular
slide the investor wanted to know if
half the titles would be on pc and
mobile will half of the profits also be
from pc and mobile by 2025. ryan
responded by saying that playstation
studios has historically executed
wonderfully in first party
narrative-rich single-player games but
we have restricted ourselves to a narrow
segment of the gaming market by
expanding to pc and mobile and live
services we have the opportunity to move
from a very narrow segment of the
overall gaming software market to being
present everywhere the opportunity for
significant growth in the number of
people who play our games is potentially
an extremely large one now to me this is
nothing but a good thing 13 year old me
would have been saying you're crazy what
are you thinking they can't put their
games on other consoles they can't put
their games on pc and from where i'm
sitting now i actually think that is not
the truth i agree with ryan here the the
potential for growth and the number of
people who are playing playstation games
is immense and at the end of the day
that's where the money is made trust me
i love hardware i love new console
launches i love the new controllers and
i think they can actually continue to
release new hardware even if they start
releasing their first party games day
and date on pc which doesn't seem like
they're doing that yet but even if they
do go that route i just think there are
enough people out there who prefer the
ecosystem of a console opposed to a pc
that they would continue to choose that
and honestly i would even love a future
where we have like a super low budget
console i actually love what microsoft
did with the xbox series s so i could
see sony releasing that super cheap
super budget friendly console for people
who just want to get into the ecosystem
then you have that sort of middle tier
which is for the wide-ranging gaming
public and then you release titles on pc
as well which is for the people who want
the absolute best top of the line
graphics top of the line performance and
for any of you who know your gaming
history you know that very often
especially early in the life of a
console the console makers very often
have to take a loss on the console and
then hope to make their money back
through things like playstation plus and
the actual sale of the games now
personally i'm in kind of an interesting
boat here where i have had a gaming pc
for a number of years now despite being
a console kid most of my life and i
definitely had a little phase where i
prefer the pc but now i actually find
myself slowly gravitating toward console
again i don't want to get too deep into
it because i know that gets a lot of
arguments going but even as someone
right now who literally has a gaming pc
sitting beside me and a console sitting
beside me there are times even when it's
some of the same games that i will
choose to play a console over the pc now
jim ryan also talked at length about the
upcoming live service games from
playstation saying they currently have
12 in development and he even believes
that if only a portion of these enjoy
what he called a critical and commercial
success the impact over time will be
completely transformational to their
business structure if you've been a fan
of playstation for a while then i
completely get why hearing this could
make you feel a bit uneasy you know
change it's difficult sometimes it
results in good things sometimes it
results in not so good things and i feel
like at least right now i feel like a
lot of playstation's core fan base are
folks who say we do not want these live
service games we want our story driven
last of us infamous uncharted these are
the style of games ghost of tsushima
this is what we want more of so trust me
i get it if you feel a little bit uneasy
and i honestly like i believe ryan and a
lot of folks at playstation i think they
do genuinely care about gamers but at
the end of the day guys it is a company
and we always have to remember
especially for someone in a position
like ryan at the end of the day he
answers to the investors and their
primary goal will always be to make more
money and so with the incredible success
of live service titles playstation would
be foolish not to try but again to so
many of us our love of playstation comes
from those single-player story driven
titles and i'll be completely straight
with you no one knows for sure what
playstation would do if these live
service games take off do they decide to
say hey you know what let's put even
more resources into this and let's kind
of slowly phase out of doing these first
party single player games that's not
what they're saying right now and
personally i don't see them abandoning
those core first party story driven
games anytime soon for one i think you
look at some of the acquisitions they've
been making they continue to build up
their stable of first party developers
by acquiring more talent like insomniac
house mark and blue point developers who
excel at those single player story
driven games how smart not so much in
the story department but in gameplay
top-notch gameplay and then hey with
returnal they did start to try and do a
little bit more with the story as well
of course bluepoint we know about their
history importing various titles they're
an incredibly talented studio that can
help in a lot of different areas plus
playstation is also in the process of
acquiring bungie whom they have said
they expect to be instrumental in
helping with these live service
endeavors so my point here is at least
right now it's not like they're taking
the team from sucker punch who made
ghosts of tsushima and saying hey we're
going to put you guys on a live service
game now or they're taking the team who
made the last of us and saying all right
you're doing live service now from
everything we've seen and heard so far
they are interested in growing the
overall business and so as they grow the
overall business a lot of times the only
way to do that is by doing new things
trying some new things while keeping
that core business focus firmly in their
view honestly the entire presentation
and subsequent q a with the investors i
think is worth a watch if you're a fan
of playstation or even just a fan of
gaming in general and kind of
understanding more about the business
side and what they're talking about i
say behind the scenes but i guess it's
not really behind the scenes because
this one's public but it definitely puts
you more in that business mindset and me
at 12 years old would have never
imagined me making a video like this
saying some of these things but i truly
believe console wars they're becoming a
thing of the past brands and services
they provide they are becoming the focus
they are becoming far more important
than the hardware itself it's about the
games it's about the ip it's about the
service much more so than the hardware i
can't wait to hear what you guys think
about this let me know in the comments
below are you looking forward to more pc
games from playstation or do you wish
they would stick to just making their
games for console as always thank you
all so much for watching i'll talk to
you again soon